[Music]
demi lovato returns to social media for
the first time since leaving rehab after
her apparent overdose for the latest on
the singer entertainment tonight's
producer Brendan joins us Brendan what
was Demi's message to her Instagram
followers today yeah she wrote her
caption was I am so grateful to be home
in time to vote one vote can make a
difference so make sure your voice is
heard now go out and vote so she along
with many other celebrities is
encouraging everyone out there to get
out and vote it is a very important time
very important day yeah Brendan I
thought this was kind of an interesting
post to kind of I don't want to say
reintroduce yourself because it's not as
dramatic as that but you know she's kind
of stepped away from social media for a
minute and then here's a perfectly
acceptable time and a perfectly
acceptable way to come back out and say
hey guys I'm out in the world and I'm
doing my thing I kind of wonder if it's
something where she knows that today is
such an important day that she didn't
really want to take away from that
obviously her story is very important
obviously so many of us want to hear her
story in here you know she's been very
vocal in the past about being sober
partying yeah all of that so I think
maybe she's waiting for that right time
she's waiting for that right platform
and maybe today she just felt like you
know it today is about people getting
out and voting so she's gonna put her
message out there but I think that we
will hear from her soon when it comes to
topic of her sobriety and not apparent
overdose that recently happened back in
July when I well when I saw this photo I
literally lit up because this situation
could have went a whole nother way you
know so to see demi out and about i
loved it and you know she was out over
the weekend can you tell us a little bit
about that Brendan right so we know on
Friday night she attended Halloween
Horror Nights with her friend Henry we
are told they are just friends that's
important to note they also had dinner
in Beverly Hills on Saturday night we
had paparazzi photos of them leaving the
restaurant there the sushi restaurant
they went to when we spoke to
eyewitnesses who saw them on Friday
night at Halloween Horror Nights vase
she looked healthy she was in really
good spirits and she was very focused on
getting to the attractions and
apparently folks at the park at
Universal didn't really bother her they
didn't approach her and they just kind
of let her be which is obviously good
her and Henry again just friends hanging
out having a good time we've learned
overnight today that Henry's also sober
they met in rehab about three years ago
and they're just kind of helping each
other through this time Demi kind of
bouncing back from that apparent
overdose in July that's you know what
I'm happy to hear you say that because
that's the exact kind of person that she
needs to be hanging out with just to
give it a little bit of context for
anybody who doesn't know Halloween
Horror Nights is a huge event here in
Los Angeles where one of our big theme
parks goes all Halloween lots and lots
of people in and masks and costumes and
so even for someone who's famous right
as Demi Lovato you can kind of skate by
and notice there and so I think that was
a perfect I'm pretty sure she was notice
but I think people gave her that
restrict like you know she just got out
of rehab let her just enjoy herself so
that says a lot about her fans as well
right I mean she for sure was noticed
the two people we spoke to said she
walked right through the front entrance
of the park you guys know I'm sure
you've both been to Universal I mean
when you walk through those gates
everyone's gonna see you but it is
interesting that no like paparazzi photo
or no one took any cell phone photos of
her but we know that she walked right
through those main gates and like I said
our eyewitnesses tell us she looked
really good really healthy and looked
like she was having a really good time
with Henry
besides being down to get scared what
and that he's sober what else do we know
about Henry so we know he's a fashion
designer again like I said we know they
met about three years ago in rehab they
became close friends immediately in
rehab he takes his uh sober life very
seriously just like we're told Demi is
taking hers now Henry is exactly the
friend that Demi needs right now that's
what one of our sources told us we know
that in the last few days they've been
spending a lot of time at Demi's home
somewhere in the LA area we're assuming
it must be a new home as you guys know
we've talked about this here on the show
before she recently listed the home
where the apparent overdose happened in
July she
put it on the market about I think a
month ago for 8.9 million dollars so we
assume they're hanging out she's must
have found another home
we know that in spending time very
low-key at a her place when they're not
out and about being spotted by the paps
I love that I'm so happy she's doing
well and I hope she continues to thrive
and just continues to bless us with her
voice and her talents all right Thank
You Brendan Thank You Brendan thanks
guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]